alors l'histoire c'est que donc ce que
ce candidat qui est un pompier de 38 ans
est donc mis en examen pour homicide
involontaire sur des faits qu'il remonte
au 10 août 2016 ou lors d'une
intervention dans dans l'hérault sur
dans une forêt dans les hauteurs de
gabian en fait dès des pompiers on est
bien évidemment vos idéaux tes
grièvement blessé et a pour pied un
jeune pompier de 24 ans est mort et les
familles et les syndicats donc on
lançait une procédure
contre eux des hauts gradés et notamment
françois qui qui qui qui voit là alors
je vous dis rliss l'histoire c'est quoi
ces constats remonte à 2016 comme dit
lors d'un incendie de forêt françois
descamps est accusé d'avoir donné à la
troupe des ordres inadaptée parfois
contradictoires et fournit une
information suivent insuffisante et des
matériels obsolètes voilà classement
bras sur sept membres c'est ça donc la
faire l'un sony avait causé la mort d'un
pompier de 24 ans et sept pompiers
avaient été mis en examen pour homicides
involontaires et blessures involontaires
alors c'est l'affairé la est ce que la
production est au courant alors la
production n'était pas n'était pas au
courant puisque son casier est vierge et
que l' enquête est en cours ça fait cinq
ans que l' enquête traîne et si vous
voulez ce qui a beaucoup choqué
notamment parmi les familles des
victimes c'est que voilà il puisse être
aujourd'hui dans l'émission avant voilà
en étant avec des valeurs de leadership
d'altruisme etc et ça ça a énormément
choqué notamment la maman du jeune
pompier qui est mort à l'âge de 24 ans
et qui a remercié le canard enchaîné sur
facebook aujourd'hui parce que elle
trouve que les valeurs que que le
monsieur voilà va propager temps dans
cette émission ne sont pas à la hauteur
de ce que eux ont vécu dans la réalité
alors vous êtes
on était que m ludovic pas avocat du
candidat mise en cause qu'est ce que
vous répondez aux gens qui disent qu'il
doit qui n'aurait pas dû être dans
l'émission je trouve que déjà c'est
commencer par la fête de dire ça il faut
commencer par le début et je vous
remercie d'avoir rappelé les faits tels
que vous en avez connaissance parce que
je trouve que finalement ça reflète bien
ce dossier hier soir avant de me coucher
j'apprends par france soir que ça y est
c'est sorti alors qu'est-ce qui est
sorti que il est mis en examen dont acte
c'est la vérité je peux pas dire le
contraire qu'il est mis en examen aux
côtés de six personnes c'est pas si ces
neuf mais peu importe en tout cas ce
qu'on comprend qu'on comprend c'est que
c'est plusieurs personnes parce que à
eux tous ils auraient peut-être commis
des fautes pas de bonne instruction peut
être là le jour matérielles etc etc ça
c'était hier soir je me lève ce matin je
prends mon café qu'est ce que je
découvre je découvre que françois
descamps lui même je le lis un chez vous
chez un concurrent n'a pas fourni le
matériel
adéquat et que de ce fait c'est de sa
faute très bien je revois mon café mai à
14 heures cette fois ci avait beaucoup
de café
il est celui auquel je vais beaucoup de
café j'espère surtout que celui que je
boirai ce soir je vais pas découvrir
autre chose et avant café de 14 heures
qu'est ce que j'apprends j'apprends que
françois descamps n'a pas fourni le bon
matériel et n'a pas donné les bonnes
directives voilà c'est à dire que si
vous m'invitez pas ce fort pour pouvoir
un peu rétablir la vérité un café de
même je prends un café je le prends et
je lis quoi mais je lis que ces pannes
homicide involontaire que c'est lui qui
a tué et après demain en buvant encore
mon café et comment falloir quelques
heures je vais dire que c'est même lui
qui a mis un terme à mon bureau et de la
tisane après le café parce que je suis
superstitieux mais en importe la pause
était pas sur les lieux au moment où
l'incident s'est produit mais en tant
que haut responsable il était resté il
était justement responsable de ce qui se
passe et de l'intervention
l'intervention qui a coûté la vie d'un
jeune pompier de 24 ans alors mise en
examen d'un candidat pour homicide
involontaire dans la nouvelle saison de
koh lanta fallait-il le coupé au montage
je veux que je leur ai dit oui oui oui
parce que m moi je vais vous le dire
très franchement votre client il a menti
au moins par omission ce qui s'est passé
c'est que
la production ne pouvait pas savoir même
rencontrant cette personne etc sans
identité qu'il était mis en examen parce
que quand les noms ont été révélés seul
le nom du responsable des pompiers a été
publié lui françois way n'a pas été cité
mais quand il est arrivé au casting de
koh lanta il était mis en examen il aura
pas d' il a montré le casier judiciaire
honnêtement m il aurait dû dire je suis
mis en examen et il ne pouvait pas
participer donc pour moi il faut le
couper au montage
gringo
[Rires]
oui mais trop de nos vies pas oui vous
savez ce que c'est que d'être mis en
examen cette rue mis en examen c'est
être près de 800 voilà le problème dans
ce dossier c'est qu'en fait aujourd'hui
il ya un espèce de tribunal médiatique
qui essaye de se substituer à la justice
le problème du tribunal médiatique c'est
à dire le tribunal auquel anciens jeux
tous à cette table et en france il n'a
pas de régler notamment la règle de la
présomption d'innocence il ne la connaît
pas parce que ce que je vais vous dire
je suis désolé je vais vous décevoir
peut-être tous et surtout décevoir n'est
pas le café ont communiqué depuis hier
ce que je vais vous dire c'est qu'en
fait sur les lieux où il a donné des
mauvaises consignes et sur les lieux où
il n'a pas fourni le bon matériel ils
n'y étaient pas françois descamps parce
qu'il ne me fais pas ce que vous avez
dit n'était pas ce qu'elle a dit elle a
dirigé sur les lieux ils n'étaient pas
gérés en fait vous savez pourquoi
françois descamps il est aujourd'hui mis
en cause dans ce dossier parce qu'il
était le responsable de la formation et
ça et qu'on a mis en cause toute la
chaîne sa part des plus hauts gradés le
responsable de la formation le
responsable du matériel ça le
responsable opérationnel et à la fin du
dossier ce qu on essaiera d'analysé
c'est que si c'est le camion qui était
en mauvais état c'est le responsable du
matériel qui responsable si c'est le
responsable de la formation qui doit
être mise en cause c'est parce qu'on
s'apercevra à la fin du dossier que ces
jeunes n'avaient pas une formation
adéquate et j'en finis parce que une
fois depuis je venais souvent personne
mais je dois dire quelque chose
d'important c'est que c'est une
responsabilité hiérarchique une
responsabilité de titres le responsable
de la formation c'est pas une
responsabilité d'homme si bien que je
vais vous donner un chiffre il a été
responsable de la formation de 2012 à
2016 et les faits interviennent en 2016
donc il est mise en examen mais savez
vous que les quatre victimes les quatre
victimes elles ont reçu leur formation
avant 2012 c'est à dire que en fait il
est mis en examen en sa qualité de
responsable de la formation alors que
c'est pas sous son égide que les
formations aurait été dommage de taxes
et je reconnais m'être qu'il a même été
promu c'est aussi pour ça que la
production était trompé il a été promu
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a connu
une ascension sociale au sein des
pompiers mais vous ne répondez pas
mettre avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour moi la question pourquoi n'at-il
pas dit au moment de koh lanta je suis
mis en examen dans cette question
d'aller dans une émission comme celle là
en étant mis en examen le jugement aura
peut-être lieu cette année mais là c'est
ça moi je moi je si tout ce que vous
nous dites là on entend pourquoi il n'a
pas dit à la prod pourquoi il n'a pas
dit voilà par contre je vais faire koh
lanta je suis sélectionné mais regardez
le camion c'est pas moi la forêt c'est
pas moi j étais pas lui je connais pas
lui c'est en 2012 lui c'est en 2008 et
la production aurait dit hé ben ok dont
j'entends ce que tu dis présomption
d'innocence tu fais l'émission quand
même ok ben tu t'en vas pas ce que tu
vas être mise en examen et on peux pas
te faire passer pour un super héros à
tf1 a une grande heure de grande écoute
faut penser à la famille aux amis
pression peut pas faire de toi un héros
ci après au jugement sa part andry la
réponse vous me demandez si en disant ça
ils auraient pu finalement expliqué à la
production qui devait bénéficier de la
présomption d'innocence et qu'il faisait
l'émission dansez sur moi ça l'aurait
jamais parce que c'est sérieux c'est le
lot
c'est leur première je vais vous dire
quelque chose ça fait moins de 24 heures
que c'est sorti et je suis chez cyril
hanouna en train de parler de ce dossier
avec un buzz comme celui là maintenant
que c'est vraiment que s'il avait dit ça
à la production on lui aurait dit on va
vous accorder le bénéfice du doute mais
voilà
ce
n'est pas la majorité mais cette fois ci
c'est à vous dire monsieur qu' il ne l'a
pas dit parce qu'on ne lui a pas posé la
question mais voilà parce que par
omission m mensonge par omission non ça
dit qu'il était mis en examen mais
pourquoi leur est il dit puisque être
mise en examen cette présumée luis ans